this is the brand new iphone 14.
and in today's video we're talking
specifically about the iphone 14 pro max
but before we dive into that
conversation let's talk about the
elephant in the room behind me you're
going to see a mac studio ultra with a
brand new studio display you're going to
see an m1 24 inch imac the latest and
greatest iphone as well as a brand new
m1 ipad pro but what we're recording
this video on is the samsung s20 ultra
see the problem what's going on guys my
name is david thomich and i'm a
registered architect here in western
australia i believe that gives me the
credentials to tell you why this iphone
14 has been architecturally designed to
perfection if you stick around to the
end of the video i'll tell you exactly
why you should buy one of these iphone
14s but more importantly why you should
buy your mum one let's start the
conversation with the latest and
greatest feature the dynamic island now
the dynamic island is something that is
truly apple and something truly special
multiple brands on the market do have
this pill shaped cutout and have had it
for years it is nothing remarkable and
it is nothing innovative in any way
shape or form but what makes it
architectural and what makes it truly
apple is its innovation and thought
process behind it apple hasn't simply
gone ahead and created a dynamic island
or a cutout in their screen that simply
lives in the middle of your screen
they've given it a purpose they've given
it a function and most importantly
they've given it a life now as an
architect we seek inspiration from the
world around us we seek how we can
create when there is nothing to be
created from so basically what apple has
done is taken nothing and created
something they've used this pill-shaped
cutout to be able to create the most
unique feature that iphone is able to
provide in the market in 2022. if you
have no idea what the dynamic island is
and you haven't seen the hundreds and
hundreds of iphone videos out there
already within the space of 10 minutes
of the iphone release what the dynamic
island is is simply a notification bar
that has been accelerated through the
use of hardware and software they've
implemented a unique software feature to
wrap around this hardware peel shaped
cutout it therefore enhances the beauty
of the pill shape cutout rather than
simply just making a defect on the
screen is able to provide you with quick
useful information that is available to
your fingertips at any point in time it
is something that is always on it is
something that is always active in the
background so the dynamic island is now
basically its own living breathing
notification center at the top of your
screen in typical apple fashion we have
a brand new feature that isn't new at
all the always-on display has been
around for years on all other devices
however apple likes to claim that
they've done something new and they've
done something innovative
unfortunately for apple this does
actually play in to their character and
what their users love
so from the very first day when the very
first iphone was released there was a
very simple feature on the iphone that
was hardware related and hasn't changed
since day one
i'm talking about the automatic
silencing switch one simple switch on
the side of your iphone is able to take
your phone from mute to loud in a matter
of seconds now this is critically
important to anybody in a meeting how
often have you seen somebody pull out
their iphone quickly switch it to silent
and put it away versus how many times
have you seen anybody pull out any other
device and try to understand how to put
this phone on silent and how to stop it
from ringing there is a very very
architectural purpose behind this and it
is truly something that apple has made
their very own now with the always on
display your phone is able to provide
you with all of these updates without
you being distracted and without you
seeming like you're being intrusive and
interruptive to anybody or any meeting
in that instance who would have thought
one iphone with three simple buttons on
the side would make such an
architectural statement in its unique
form design and creativity something
that is truly important to every
architect and anybody that works outside
quite frequently is the display
brightness now the new iphone 14 has a
16 knit brightness with a peak
brightness of over 2000 nits which makes
it as bright and as powerful as the pro
xdr display when you are outside on site
trying to capture the perfect photo or
the perfect moment or even that
instagram shot to promote your business
and your brand you're not going to be
able to do it successfully if your phone
can't compete with the sun
every single year apple endeavors to
make this truly better and this year
they've truly stepped it up well and
above beyond anybody's expectations now
photography and videography are critical
to any architect or any professional
looking to build their brand and their
business however everything that apple
talks about in their event about this
iphone 14 basically most common people
have no idea what they're talking about
so let me break it down for you in how
it can actually be used in everyday life
in a real setting the 48 megapixel quad
pixel sensor is what everybody's going
to be talking about for months to come
but what is a 48 megapixel quad pixel
sensor let me define it in layman's
terms that will make sense to most
people it is a 48 megapixel camera which
means it is relatively large format it
uses pixel bending technology to
automatically create four pixels down
into one so therefore it allows you to
produce better photos in better
low-light conditions and harsh
environments to a simple smaller
resolution photo so you will always get
the same photo size you are used to but
you will have significantly better
results pixel binning has been around
for a very long time but what makes it
special is the innovative technologies
inside the a16 bionic chip the a16
bionic now has an intelligent processor
specifically designed to bin these
pixels that means as more photos are
taken throughout the iphone network the
smarter this system is going to get the
better the ai is going to get and the
better your photos are progressively
going to get over time now nobody can
guarantee that the photo taken today
will be better than the photo taken
tomorrow but in layman's terms that is
the overall intention behind pixel
binning through an ai system in the a16
bionic chip you might be thinking as
well great we have three cameras on the
back like we always have what's the
difference well the 48 megapixel main
sensor is now a 24 millimeter focal
length with a 48 millimeter focal length
when you go to 2x zoom again david stop
using all these big terms and start
explaining it in layman's terms
basically the 24 millimeter and the 48
millimeter lenses are critical in
photography most photographers will use
anything from a 16 mil to a 24
millimeter to capture the perfect
landscape shot whilst they'll go all the
way up to a 50 millimeter to capture the
perfect portrait so in your back pocket
now you have a 24 millimeter and a 48
millimeter both in that
megapixel camera system with the larger
sensor that can take amazing photos for
either landscape or portrait not to
mention the ultra wide camera is also a
macro camera that means you're allowed
to come as close as you want to be able
to define those subjects and define
those details as we all know architects
love to get up close and personal with
their details and we truly love to
capture the finest details we possibly
can now here's where it gets interesting
imagine you're out on site somewhere in
the middle of nowhere typical remote
australia you're walking through the
long grass and a nostalgic sound place
all of a sudden your world flashes and a
wild snake appears
before you even have time to pull out
your pokeball and choose pikachu
unfortunately that snake has bitten you
poisoned you and escaped you're down to
the count nowhere to go nowhere to run
no reception more importantly and you're
looking at death right in the eye so
what happens in this situation well with
any other mobile phone you're most
likely going to die unfortunately that
is a sad reality however with the iphone
14 now for the first time ever you have
satellite emergency communication
basically allowing you to use any
satellite in the sky to get an sos
message out this feature could truly be
the difference between a phone that
saves your life and a phone that just
sits in your pocket now let's take this
a little bit further imagine if you sent
that message to your mum she jumps in
the car hits the nitrous button and
drives like dominic toretto
unfortunately she's dominic toretto in
the first movie and that train clips the
side of her car the brand new iphone 14
has inbuilt crash detection which will
automatically send an sos emergency
signal to allow emergency services to
come to her rescue the moral of the
story is if you're gonna buy yourself an
iphone make sure you buy your mum one
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video if you did there's
a playlist to the side of me with more
great architectural content and if you
loved the video make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below but like
always i'll see you next monday